now there are some very big and very
complicated questions to
try to answer about the universe and if
you're a geek
like me and we're a big fan of
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy
remember that
deep thought was asked what is the
meaning of life the universe and
everything the answer was 42 rather
confusingly
um but one man who could hopefully shed
a bit more light on it all is someone
who's
i mean world famous for the way that he
just makes things
accessible to all of us astrophysicist
neil degrasse tyson and he joins me now
i am so excited it's really good to see
you this morning
i mean how do you even be how do you
begin to break things down i know you've
got
in your new book you're trying to make
everything accessible to all of us
how do you even begin to tackle that
well
thanks for that hitchhiker's guide intro
to this
uh here's the here's the difference
between the hitchhiker's guide and this
book
uh in that one the great question
uh what is the answer to like the
universe and everything
and it's 42. um and then you say what
what what in the case of cosmic queries
it's a celebration
of the questions even more than it is a
celebration of the answers
and if you take a look through the
history of civilization
and ask one of the deepest questions
we've ever posed
those are addressed in the book you know
how did it all get here
what's it all made of are we alone in
the universe
how will it all end and these are
questions that
that grew out of a podcast that i host
called star talk
one of the formats of the show is just
called cosmic queries
and people people ask you know all kinds
of questions but some of them were
deeper than others
and those were collected for this book
and not all the questions have answers
and that's that's the fun part of it
because as a scientist you need to learn
to love the questions themselves
i was going to say with this with
science we would like to think of
science as being something where we get
a definitive answer
but the more we delve into science and
particularly sort of astrophysics
i mean the fewer answers we have yeah
there's a fun
uh expression to kept to encapsulate
that it's
as the area of our knowledge grows
so too does the perimeter of our
ignorance
and so you know it's like wow yeah
that's kind that's true
isn't it so as as a scientist when
you're on the frontier that's that can
be a very bleeding edge
you know where you don't even
necessarily know if you're
asking the right question i'll give a
quick example
uh probably the number one question or
number two question i get asked
is as an astrophysicist that i get asked
is what was around
before the big bang and we have some
ideas
but let me also pose the possibility
that maybe the
question has no meaning and you'll say
well of course it does it's got the
nouns and verbs in the right place and
it's got a question mark
so of course it does now wait a minute
um let's visit santa claus
all right we all know he's on the north
pole we say santa
which way is north and every direction
santa points is due south
on the north pole the question which way
is north
has no meaning and we know that
all right so maybe what was around
before the big bang
has no meaning we don't know that
because we're on the frontier
wow i love that i mean it's it's that
sort of thing that just makes the brain
melt
a little a little bit does it but but
that's but that's part of the joy of all
of this i mean i think particularly for
for young people i know this book is
aimed at at all ages
but for young people their minds are
somehow a little bit more
flexible aren't they to get to to get
get their heads around some of this
that's so polite to say that their minds
are flexible which is an indictment of
the adult mind
which is to say we are ossified in one
way of thinking this is this is why you
need to not only
learn to love the questions um i'd like
to think of cosmic queries as a
celebration of curiosity
and and thanks for showing some of those
images and the pages of the book
well that's a video that isn't but
others work directly from the book
where um this the book is produced by
national geographic so
it's beautiful um there's also just to
keep you going kind of rewards for
getting past various pages
there's a series of tweets that were
live
actual tweets that i had posted related
to
the content and they're just fun things
like
um yes you learned the universe is
expanding but
that won't get you out of this traffic
jam you're in the street
you know little things just to like
biscuits to
to help you guide you through the book
but um
yes the the the the the the
depth of the frontier exists at all
levels in chemistry and biology and
physics
astrophysics and and it's all there it's
i mean it's it's
it's really of science that we
we spend a lot of time uh looking at the
very smallest parts of
of what is what we have what exists
and at the same time applying that to
the furthest outreaches of
what we can see and somehow i don't i
don't quite know how but it does all
sort of tie together doesn't it i mean
it's the whole sort of
quantum theory and quantum entanglement
all this sort of stuff which i i'd love
to read about but still don't understand
yeah so you mentioned a very important
point and it didn't have to be this way
it's you you're on a tabletop you
perform experiments and establish sort
of
the laws of chemistry and physics and
and then you look out in the universe
and say hey
that's happening there too the same
chemical elements on earth are on other
planets on other galaxies
hey the laws of gravity that we
experience here
are controlling the large-scale universe
now i suppose it didn't have to be that
way everything on earth could have just
been unique to earth
and we might still have science but it'd
be a very local activity
so um you know as you say
on earth as it is in the heavens right
it is it's throughout
and that's remarkable and it empowers us
to not only have thoughts about the
nature of the universe
but to address them and answer them with
some kind of confidence
i wonder what do you think we've lost
over the years because one thing always
i've always found fascinating is when
you look back to some of the ancient
civilizations
and then there's the pyramids and the
the incas and all these sort of things
where they
they seem to have had this this um sort
of
astronomical understanding which is
incredible we can't work out how
how they knew so much when they did you
think we sort of lost some knowledge
along the way
well first of all they were still human
right they weren't like not human oh
weren't they
have a
i'm a bit of a conspiracy theory to that
i do wonder
yeah it is it is it is weird that people
go to africa find pyramids
and rather than credit native africans
for making it
they'll say oh the aliens helped them
all right that's
that's being very sort of eurocentric on
that one
but yes the the and by the way not
everyone presumably designed the
pyramids you had the brilliant
few among them who are the engineers and
the architects and this sort of thing
and like i said they were a human like
us today so they had the same
curiosities
the same capacity to solve a problem
they just had less
technology so it took them way longer to
build a pyramid than
we would take us to build it today i
think
but but um yeah it's it's i'm delighted
that the science and the architecture
and in many cases the art
is almost what we define as the
arc of civilization coming forward and
politicians are long forgotten and all
other aspects of society but
what have you built and what what were
your philosophy how did you think
about the world these are the things
that have shaped who we are
and ultimately where we're going if we
if we are wise
shepherds of the scientific powers
that we have gleaned wow i mean i love
the fact i would talk
i did so i think maybe we'll get some
answers you've left me with more
questions which i think is the whole
point of the book as well
it's such a joy to talk to you thank you
so much indeed
excellent thank you for having me